muhammad asks uh a live question here
can you share a few insights on what
data points you consider the most
valuable while iterating on product this
is a great question and it obviously
varies by the type of product so let's
go with the sas product first and then
we'll go to a consumer product
yeah so the way i like to think about it
is you can break it down into three sort
of categories the the first category is
very qualitative but it's about the
value that you deliver to your customers
and it's about crystallizing the
articulation of that value in a way
where you can say this is what we do
that our customers love and then i can
ask your customers and they say this is
what we love and those two things are
the same thing which sometimes they're
not but that's really the secret is it
the customers oh this is why i push a
button and a car shows up my door that's
awesome or i can put up my screenshots
and i can work with them really easily
and it's the best app in the world for
doing the second sort of category that
we have is the metrics of your business
and those are really simple
straightforward and you can go deep dive
into sas metrics and at the end of the
day it's how much does it cost to
acquire a customer how much do they pay
you how much do they use your product
how long do they stick around and
of course we have those numbers we can
understand where the business is going
to go
relative to pretty close like down to to
individual decimal we have people in the
industry who specialize in doing late
stage sas funding and they do all kinds
of formulas and they will understand
your business and customer base chamath
was doing this at social capital uh sax
is doing it at craft there were other
people who specialized this they started
coming up with their own formulas how
much money did you spend this year on
your sales team versus your net new arr
they're just figuring out all these kind
of things i'll talk a little bit about a
ratio that really matters depending on
the product which is how many monthly
active users do you have okay great we
now know let's just pick a number you
have a million people a month who use
your product okay now what percentage of
the daily what's the daily active user
to monthly active user in other words
are people coming once a month to check
their bill or to use the product to
watch one tv show or something or
are they on snapchat or tick tock every
night for four hours how many sessions
are they opening up so those ratios in a
consumer product become really
interesting to understand exactly how
sticky is a term people used to use but
just the level of engagement a fancy
term engagement is a fancy term
stickiness is a fancy term for the
number of minutes how often people use
your product and you can do all kinds of
interesting ratios and if people use
your product more that generally
indicates product market fit they're
getting delighted because people are so
busy
that to get their attention
is a big win so if you were calm the
meditation app
and people were using it three times a
month the chances of them churning down
the road would be less than if somebody
used it three times a year
and if they used it three times a week
maybe that person churns less so that's
where getting users to use your product
more helps what's an example of how
somebody could increase usage of a
product streaks there's a thing you've
done this many days in a row of fasting
in your fasting app of working out on
your peloton
of uh sending a message to another
person in snapchat or doing meditations
in
com so doing just doing something as
simple as that stupid feature you're on
a five day streak around a seven day
streak could
greatly increase the engagement and
that's a sign of strength those are but
some of the important metrics and then
you will create metrics inside your
company
to motivate your team and boy just be
careful
with incentives because if you motivate
your team on daily active users too much
then they might do things to goose that
number that are unnatural so you don't
want to have unnatural knacks acts like
firing off too many notifications
because then people will turn off
notifications because you're being too
annoying so make sure you're not you you
don't motivate your team too much and
put them on tilt to do something
unnatural
i think is important yeah do we miss
anything there at metrics there's a
whole world right yeah
from there we talked about consumer we
talked about sas did i miss any is there
anything missing there
i mean growth i think one of the things
that you always have to come back to
the sort of third category in my book is
growth and understanding growth across
your cohorts of users and across your
channels and down to the down as
incremental as you can possibly get is a
critical part of any business because if
you ain't growing you'd be dead
basically our industry is about growth
if you can't grow
vcs might take a meeting with you
because a friend begged them to or
whatever but
if you are growing conversely you email
any vc any angel any seed fund and
you're growing 20 or more for three
months or more you're getting a meeting
let me say that one more time
if you're growing 20 or more for three
or more months that means you doubled
your business in but three to four
months right the rule of 72 divide a
time period divide a growth rate into
the number 72 that's the time period if
you're going 25 a week that means every
three weeks you're doubling if you're
going 25 a year every three years to
doubling if you're going 25 a month
every three months if you can show
you're doubling every three to six
months you're gonna get a meeting and it
really is that simple it doesn't matter
how ugly your deck are it is how ugly
you are how ugly your clothes are you
got a big pasta saying if you showed up
with a pasta
stain and spaghetti down your white
press shirt and you look like a hobo
and you got 30 month-over-month growth
for three or four months in this town
you're getting the meeting and you're
probably getting the check here's the
check
here's the check
don't knock over their grandmother to
get you the check before another vc
over the past few years everyone has
been talking about no code and one of
the first no code web app tools was
bubble empowers people to design and
launch their own apps marketplaces or
tools without needing coding skills or
pricey engineers bubble offers a digital
editor and cloud hosted platform for as
low as 29 a month users can build pretty
much any complex web app from
marketplaces to social networks to sas
tools and more why is bubble so great
for founders because you can spend 10
times less on building out your mvp
bubble utilizes drag and drop elements
in their visual editor so users can
quickly and easily build powerful apps
go from idea to launchable product in a
matter of days or weeks not months and
they handle all the annoying stuff like
deployment and hosting so you can focus
on your product and customers bubble has
over 1 million users worldwide and
enables over 1 billion in business
volume their founder and ceo emanuel was
on episode 1021 back in january of 2020
so you can check that out if you want to
learn more and bubble is offering one
month free on any of their paid plans
ranging from their personal plan of 29 a
month to their production plan of 529 a
month but act best because they're only
offering this deal for the first 500
redemptions head to bubble.io slash
twist and snag one of those 500 coupons